off the top right now at five breaking
news involving the police shooting of a
man earlier this week new video showing
the moment he held a gun up to officers
and good evening to you thank you for
joining us at five i'm bryan loftis and
i'm denise valdez so let's get right
over to 8 news now i-team's david charns
with more on this compelling video david
denise and bryan metro police just
wrapping up a briefing saying a man was
breaking into a trailer at a mobile home
park where he also lived video shows him
then pointing a gun at officers and i do
want to warn you before we play this
that this video may be disturbing
hey mike mike listen man nothing's
changed we're still here to help you
just drop it drop it drop it mike drop
it we're here to help you
all right sit that gun down
mike set it down set it down
mike we're here to help you put the gun
down
police say three officers filed a total
of 11 rounds at 41 year old michael
allensworth in this mobile home park
near downtown that was monday they say
they tried to de-escalate the situation
for nearly a half hour before
allensworth then as you saw there raised
his gun toward them this is how the
assistant sheriff described what led up
to police arriving
i will tell you that what we have
learned from speaking with the homeowner
of the trailer that was burglarized is
that
there had been an interaction the day
before and it appears that allensworth
came back to the trail the next day to
have a confrontation with the
homeowner of the trailer that was being
burglarized
ellensworth was armed with a pistol he
did not fire any rounds now this marks
the fifth officer-involved shooting in
metro's coverage area so far this year
at this time last year there were three
i'm david charns live local now